all right jesse hi jesse uh where'd you
grow up where are you from
originally originally from maryland
maryland yep
and tell me about your childhood you had
both your parents when you were young
what about my parents tell me about your
your family you had both your parents i
had a very uh
relatively normal upbringing in uh the
suburbs of maryland
um my father was a contractor and i
worked for him
we i have two two older brothers and
then a little a
younger sister came along ten years
later four kids
grandparents in the city grandparents in
the country
and we lived in the suburbs how would
you describe your childhood what how
would you describe your childhood
it was uh pretty idyllic you know
we were very lucky my father worked very
hard my mother was a good housewife
you went through high school i went to
high school i graduated
delaney high school in maryland
you go further college i went to college
i waited a couple years and then i went
as an older returning student i went to
towson state university it took me
seven years to get my bachelor's degree
i got academically dismissed uh once
and then i got i got uh
kick kicked off the campus one time for
a
situation with a woman and uh
tell me where your life is taking you
after that you've done what kind of work
i uh unfortunately at that point
towson state university is not too far
from baltimore maryland which is a
heart heart and soul the crack and
heroin epithelia epidemic
and i met a beautiful young
young young girl
that i was in love with and we decided
to get a place
and we found a nice little row house in
baltimore
i found a nice little row house in
baltimore for us to live in
and we had been together for seven years
seven years and i was finally ready to
move in with her and i graduated college
and she left left me for this this guy
this guy named steve was an actor and i
fell apart
i just lost it and i'm down there in
baltimore
and i didn't know any better and i
thought
i saw the signs that said uh i saw the
billboards
that made that they were uh saying how
bad crack cocaine is
and i said oh that that i know i'm
college educated now
so i learned that uh the media had
overblown
uh the effects of marijuana and the
overblown the uh
the um the lsd was blown out of
proportion i figured oh well this is
just
the same thing so
one day i uh
picked up this young lady and brought
her to my apartment is
a pretty very attractive black girl
and uh
she said i want to get some uh crack
cocaine
i said all right and she went and got it
and came back
and uh that was the beginning of the end
of this i've been struggling with that
stupid
thing ever since however
i'm doing really well today i'm on the
other side of it yes i've managed it
i've i've engaged in harm reduction
i've engaged in uh actually writing a
book about the whole thing
what what techniques have you found
effective in getting away from crack
there's a there's a a hundred different
things that are important
with with managing uh what i refer to as
unproductive unhealthy
unproductive unhealthy repetitive
behaviors herbs
we all engage in them
and uh one trick is to engage in harm
reduction
you're familiar with the harm reduction
that's no i guess i'm not harm reduction
is for example if you're shooting heroin
instead of shooting it snorting it or if
you're
smoking crack cocaine instead of smoking
it snort it
that's harm reduction sure or harm
reduction is only do it on the weekends
or harm reduction is keep it to a
certain amount if you're an alcoholic
if you're able to drink a couple beers
you can do it some people can't
some people have to completely uh be
abstinent
yeah so i've taken a little bit from uh
i've been around i've been around i've
done a lot of things in my life
i've been a stan i did i did stand-up
comedy for 17 years professionally
you know i have a degree in sociology
i've i've been in bands i've traveled
around the country i've traveled across
the country uh
two dozen times and through the uh
through comedy i discovered the rainbow
gatherings the hippie thing
rainbow gatherings they gather in the
national forest every year
a lot of pot no bad drugs
no alcohol and i learned a lot from the
rainbow gatherings
every year they gather in the middle of
the national forest july 1st
you told me that you're nomadic twenty
thousand people yes i'm nomadic i travel
so you don't you don't have a home
really i don't where
so you'll stay with uh friends or in
your car i've i've i have friends all
over the country
and i stay people's houses occasionally
i'll
i'll get a place uh i had a wife for two
years and we lived in a place for two
years
you have kids what do you have children
no no children
so what uh what brings you to the
tenderloin here in san francisco
you're gonna love this so i did stand up
for 17 years and i
the idea to come out west was to uh
do a persona outlaw comic jessex i came
out west
the intention to be a part of burning
man
specifically and the new age culture in
general
and uh
got i started going to the festivals i
did a few shows as the outlaw jessex
you know they said i did stand up
professionally so i was pretty good at
it
but i started distributing psychedelics
at the festivals
because there's no police and there's no
uh
uh you know every psychedelics are
perfectly um
[Music]
safe in my opinion in fact uh
i think it's pretty obvious uh lately in
the news you can tell that
everybody's realizing that people using
psychedelics to stay away from hard
drugs
mushrooms molly ketamine lsd et cetera
and i became so good at distributing
psychedelics i became
so successful at it that i kind of gave
up the comedy idea
and just started working the festivals
nomadically march through october
so every year march through october i'm
nomadic
and then i make enough money me and the
other vendors
the goal is to make enough money to last
through the winter
some of them go to other countries some
of them stay here
and unfortunately during covid
the festival shut down and so for 15
months
i've been living in my car in the bay
area
trying desperately not to do
peruvian love rock that's what i refer
to it as
crack cocaine i don't use the c-r-a-c-k
word anymore
that's going to be in the book words are
important yes
yeah so you're going to love this yes
this is
paulie gray who's a
person who works at needle exchange
and i have decided we want to do a class
to teach people
how to effectively smoke peruvian love
rock
in order to get a in order to quit in
other words
it is our opinion that one reason why
people are addicted to or they keep
doing
smoke it over and over again because
they don't know how to do it they don't
know why to do it they don't know
the physics of smoking cocaine
so if you teach somebody how to do it
you teach somebody to take control of it
see somebody take control of the drug
and then they've learned that they can
control it
then they can more easily stop that's
one way one way is aa
abstinence another way is harm reduction
another way
is take control of your life
that's what that's my point that's the
point of the book
that's the point of the class
right but you're still down here today
yes because
because uh i'm here today
honestly i'm being honest you told me
you're very honest i'm being i'm
being very honest i occasionally still
like to smoke peruvian love rock
occasionally
normally i just try to use uh ken i've
uh
i've discovered ketamine i originally
just distributed mushrooms
at the festivals because they're pure
and everybody can see them and they're
easy to sell and nobody's worried
and then i added molly because i heard
all the kids talking about molly and i
googled it and i researched it i felt
like it was okay
and then about three years ago i
discovered ketamine
ketamine is fascinating substance and it
has
absolutely absolutely been the major
tool helping me stay away
from crack cocaine staying away from
smoking peruvian love rock to excess
how bad did your crack addiction get how
did how bad did it get yeah
i got arrested two dozen times in san
francisco i got arrested in baltimore
at least a dozen times and the last time
i spent
nine months it was horrible
horrible
completely traumatizing
nine months and it was
95 african-american i learned a lot
about the african-american community in
baltimore i learned a lot about
what goes on
you know the inner workings you know
like uh what's the name of the
show in baltimore
the corner i mean
the hbo the very popular hbo
series i'm sorry i don't know
it's extremely popular hbo series on uh
crack addiction in uh
in some of the some of the shows and
they
showed that they show the uh the inside
scoop
from the political side from the money
side from the
from the dealers and the politics and
all that went on
i saw it from the from the
trenches in the streets
i saw horrible things in baltimore
i had 30 i i recently i was the last
time i was held against my will is
marine county jail 11 months and while i
was there i decided to
write down all the physical trauma i've
ever had
i thought it would be a couple dozen
33 physical drama traumas
prior to doing any bad drugs like
falling off the car and hit my head
falling off the bunk hit my cracking my
head open on the thing 33 different
physical traumas
when i was a kid just regular kid stuff
33 physical traumas
in baltimore getting hit in the head
with a gun
or having uh
uh black drug dealers beat me up
put me in the hospital and then 33
physical traumas in san francisco 99 all
together
and then it's been five years since i
was i was out of jail i'm never going to
be in jail again
and i've had 17 since then so 116
different instances of physical trauma
people like to beat me up because i have
a big mouth
does everybody get in trouble yeah i
speak my mind
and also it i'm you know pretty small
let me use it i'm easy to beat up did
uh did your prison time help you
limit or reduce your crack use
they assume you're cleaning it's
complicated
absolutely no one should ever be held
against their will for doing drugs
i never never ever was he was one
glaring exception i never did anything
against anybody's will
i never engaged in any crime
that was me that was all the crimes were
consensual
or victimless all drugs
you should there should be another
option
but it is good to sit it's a good it's
good to sit for 30 days or 60 days
but that's the most you should have to
sit for if you're doing drugs 30 to 60
days
90 tops no one should ever be held
against their will for
buying or selling drugs it's ridiculous
it's horrible it's a horrible horrible
experience it's
completely traumatizing it dehumanizes
you it strips you down
it affects you deeply deeply for the
rest of your life
i'm just now getting over the the last
time i was held against my will
now i'd say about a year ago
i got over the trauma of being held for
11 months they were trying to put me in
prison
why do you think drugs are so popular in
our culture today
because america has no soul
so we're all about money so many so many
families are so many families are broken
so many people
we don't have any community we don't
have uh you know we're not like other
countries there's no
there's no ethnic cohesion there's no uh
collective consciousness
it's a wild country it's a great country
if you're uh
if you're uh if you're doing well
financially
it's not such a good country if you're a
working class and you don't understand
there's no community we need communities
yeah it just seems to me if you stand
back and look at it
there's a lot of greed going on in the
united states absolutely a lot of it
right
a lot of greed and that if you boil it
down kind of leads
to a lot of parts of our society that
are just broken and they have no options
absolutely they have no way no hope of
ever
surviving unless they go to you know
criminal behavior absolutely and that's
one reason why i'm helping out at this
the exciting thing is
there's a lot of wonderful things that
are happening there's a new breed of
politician
and there's a new energy to help the
homeless
i think one huge
aspect of the homeless
challenge is that nobody recognizes how
direct how much there's a direct
connection between the drug war and
homelessness
the overwhelming majority of the people
are homeless are black the overwhelming
majority of those black people are men
and their men have been held against
their will one reason why they don't
want to be housed
is because they get anxious when they're
inside because you get traumatized when
the doors close
they don't want to be inside
it's traumatizing to be in an apartment
building it's
amazing it causes anxiety yeah i buy
that to me but
mental health is the issue behind the
drugs absolutely mental health is the
issue
absolutely and that might be caused by
things like we just talked about it's
very complicated it's very complicated
but homelessness is not the problem
drugs are not the problem i would say
mental health is probably
what we should look at it it's it's
complicated and
super complicated we need to come we
need to have a holistic cause sometimes
the drugs cause the mental health we
have a holistic approach
yeah and uh that's what's exciting about
this uh community space that i'm helping
with there's a
there's a homeless encampment in oakland
they call it the wood street encampment
it's at west grand and wood street
it's the most wild renegade desolate
[ __ ] crazy homeless encampment i've
ever seen
and uh these women these women activists
these neighborhood uh women activists
um one has a i forget one is
called sochil another one is anne-marie
i can't remember the name of their
organizations but they
asked miguel who owns an entity called
cobbling wood he builds
straw and mud um
structures internationally and
nationally
he builds them all over the all over the
world
mostly in this country though uh he
builds them where people
need uh structures um
where there's uh not necessarily
uh direct access to water and
electricity
and so they asked them to come out and
build these structures
in the middle of the homeless encampment
so directly in the middle of all these
burned out cars and uh uh
abandoned vehicles and rvs that look
like hell and dirt roads
and the highways are occurring there's
this beautiful community space it's been
created in the last five months
there's a kitchen a working kitchen with
hot water and a refrigerator
and a shower a hot shower i don't know
how he did it
he ran the he ran the wires underneath
the ground
from uh from uh caltrans or something
and uh and there's a free store
with every uh closing and then there's a
medical athena and there's a stage and
every sunday
uh four to eight with pizza and beer and
they have open mic
and people come and sing and there's a
big crowd it's been
very exciting and it it's uh this is the
homeless
it's a it's a it's what this is a
homeless community
it's it's in the middle of the homeless
encampment and july 1st caltrans
has uh uh
put up notice that they're going to
evict them all right so there's a big
fight coming up
wow interesting yeah and i'm going to
film a video there
a music video of the song i wrote while
i was held against my will
called everyone's an outlaw that's the
end of june but that's not important one
important
important thing is that these people
who are at the homeless encampments they
need
community and they need to feel safe and
they need showers
and food to help them get out of there
yeah i think a little dignity and
exact respect exactly go a long way in
terms of helping people
ever climb out of this lifestyle and
it's gotten a lot of press
and it's got it's very exciting and it
looks like it's going to be
uh something that is going to be a game
changer for the homelessness
for the homeless yeah yeah san francisco
seems very
advanced in terms of how it treats the
home san francisco
god you look at a challenge
you look at the way the homeless are
treated in other cities and it's
well i look at this problem here it is
i i'm pretty sure i have a lot of the
answers but
san francisco is overwhelming
it's overwhelming i i i walk down the
streets and i cry
because it's going to be very very
difficult
to end this thing but it's going to
happen
it's definitely going to happen they're
putting money into it and there's energy
and people are coming out and
what's very important is for
is for the uh the people to come out
in in berkeley in berkeley where i live
and where i park my car my tent people
come up and bring us food now
there's places where you can go to eat
but there's the energy has changed and
some
maybe maybe because of covid maybe
because people have free time
people have come out of their houses and
given clothing
they come to my place and give me food
they come to my tent and bring me food
and i can't tell you how many times i've
been sitting there and i couldn't i did
i was
i was having a relapse and i couldn't
make it to the
to eat and somebody shows up a [ __ ]
home-cooked meal it's unbelievable i
mean it's unbelievable
it's so inspiring and so that's
that's what people need to do people
need to talk to
to the homeless i know you can't talk to
people when they're all [ __ ] up you
can't talk to people when they're high
at the time but you can talk to them
when they're not high
and you can try to help them
and you can have compassion for them
absolutely
and you can just give them things they
need don't give them money
don't ever give homeless people money
i'm learning that yeah don't give
those people cash
um generally speaking generally speaking
there are exceptions
yeah exactly but uh
if someone needs food give them food
someone needs clothing
give them clothing someone needs a tent
if someone needs a hug
if someone needs to talk sometimes more
importantly sometimes they just need
some
respect and and some respect absolutely
absolutely absolutely and to not be
treated like a pariah
for being addicted when you're addicted
god i've seen
my addiction is you know is
relatively benign but
i've
gotten to know i've been around people
and when you're addicted to
methamphetamine or heroin or fentanyl
it is very very very hard to stop
it's very very challenging
yeah well hopefully we'll move the
society forward a little bit what's that
maybe society will move forward a little
bit become a little more understanding
and
yeah and kinder i think there's a lot of
hope
i really do i think there's a lot of
hope and this
this uh project that i'm helping with
is inspiring excellent
all right well jesse thank you so much
for talking with me thanks i
i appreciate you asking this has been
good for me actually
excellent you're very interesting yeah
i'm an interesting guy
thank you very much
you